make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we are getting one step closer to
covering all of the omega-level mutant
that exists within Marvel Comics here on
the channel by discussing one of the
most notorious mutants in the Marvel
Universe which is Magneto you know when
I was a little kid here's kind of a
funny story here when I was a little kid
and I'm curious which one you guys think
it is I had a buddy of mine named ace
and he and I used to go back and forth
because ace always said that magneto was
pronounced Magneto
and I've heard it go both ways and I'm
curious which one you guys think it is
I'm kind of curious about that anyway as
we covered in our previous videos might
need to explain different things like
that
magneto was created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and made his first appearance in
issue number one of the x-men in 1963 as
the primary antagonist of the team now
in the coming years we learned that
Magneto's real name was max Eisenhart
and that he was born in Germany in the
1920s to Jewish parents as Germany came
to power however Mac and his family fled
to Poland but were captured and sent to
live in the warsaw ghetto they did
manage to escape but his family were
captured once more and the rest of them
were all executed for max himself he was
eventually captured as well and sent to
the Auschwitz extermination camp where
he was reunited with a girl named Magna
who he knew back home and who he had
fallen in love with and ultimately the
two of them would escape the camp in a
prisoner revolt in 1944 max then changes
his name to Erik Lehnsherr he and Magda
moved to Ukraine they have a daughter in
live a quiet life until some of his
powers manifest in front of his employer
after that he gets back home the people
in the town realized what was going on
and ultimately they end up trying to
lead a revolt to run magneto out his
daughters burned alive in the house that
they lived in magneto loses his mind
uses his powers and kills everybody
around him scaring his wife and sending
her running for her life following that
magneto changed his name for a second
time moves to Israel and meets and
becomes friends with Charles Xavier now
neither magneto nor Xavier know the
other is a mutant until they're attacked
by Hydra forces and have to use their
powers to fight them off throughout
their conversations with one another it
became clear that magneto and Charles
had very different views on how mutants
should coexist with humans with Charles
preferring the two species live in
harmony with one another and magneto
believing that mutants were superior to
humans and should rule over them all
ultimately due to the fact that humans
would inevitably try to destroy mutants
out of fear this disagreement ultimately
leads to magneto leaving Israel only to
resurface years later as a supervillain
we know today battling the x-men it
keeps Citadel in the team's first
mission since this time he has remained
a constant presence in the x-men
sometimes as a villain and sometimes as
a hero and oftentimes something in
between but always in a position of
prominence
now although magneto is an omega-level
mutant he technically only has one power
although we can use it in a variety of
different ways and what I mean by that
is Magneto's mutant power simply allows
him to manipulate electromagnetic fields
but this allows him to do several things
in and of itself - the most common
application of this ability is the
manipulation and control of metal
objects if there is a limit to how much
metal magneto could control at once it
has not been revealed but we have seen
him achieve some incredibly impressive
feats of metal manipulation for example
he moved 37 satellites at Earth's orbit
simultaneously from the Earth's surface
he's also proven capable of balancing a
platform weighing two million pounds on
top of a spire only one meter wide not
only that he's easily able to destroy
mountains and raise cities in an instant
perhaps the most impressive feat in
terms of sheer mass of an object was
when he pulled the breakworld bullet a
metal bullet the size of a city the
Kitty Pryde had been trapped in and
unable to face through from the deep
reaches of outer space all the way back
to earth
this feat took nearly every ounce of
strength and concentration magneto can
muster and almost cost him his life
magneto is also able to use his powers
on a much smaller scale as well you'll
all probably be familiar with the time
magneto rippy adamantium from Wolverine
skeleton which would require him to use
his powers with a great deal of
precision but he can actually be far
more precise than that he could actually
exploit the microscopic amounts of metal
in a person's body to affect their
behavior for example he has manipulated
the iron in the blood stream of his
enemies to cause paralysis seizures
strokes amnesia and has even been able
to control the movements of individuals
utilizing only the tiny amount of metal
in their bodies he can use this ability
to alter the blood flow of others and to
also exploit or turn off the pain
receptors in their brains now on
repeated occasions and I mean a lot of
occasions magneto has used his powers to
throw objects in orbit including
satellites such as Graymalkin and the
asteroid avilon both of which are the
size of planets he was able to disrupt
the magnetic field surrounding planets
and has even been able to stop Forrest
hammer mjolnir by altering the magnetic
field around it he could create
extremely durable magnetic shields that
have blocked attacks from Cyclops havoc
cosmic spider-man and Phoenix among
others his ability to fly is due to his
manipulation of the magnetic field
around him and because of the close
relationship between
magnetism and electricity he can also
generate and manipulate lightning so
yeah
magneto is super-powerful here's the
question that I have for you guys but
here's the question that I want to know
from you guys I want to know what your
favorite moment from Magneto is in
Marvel Comics and here's reason why
magneto what Marvel Comics is is really
one of the most interesting characters
right just in terms of the small moment
that he had but if those are guys who
were curious about the time magneto stop
force hammer that actually happens a
journey in a mystery issue number 109
but as most people all probably know my
favorite moment with Magneto its fatal
attractions right like so here's the
thing fatal attractions is like the
quintessential Magneto story like it's
literally the story where my needle rips
the adamantium out of Wolverines bones
and I love that whole thing where at
least riffs that off of off of
Wolverines books like I love that whole
thing because it was like weed I mean
we'd seen different displays of power
but that was the first time we've seen
something so extreme and that recon cuz
the way this goes down when I fellows
you guys you were familiar with this
bear with me here but the way this goes
down did you end up essentially having
this scenario where like magneto tries
to basically pull all these different
Newtons off earth the x-men end up
responding and when they get there like
a fight breaks out between Wolverine and
Magneto himself and Wolverine is just
kind of like this feral and not really
feral straight out but like this guy who
just kind of usually goes in swinging
his claws mic just goes in and attacks
magneto manages to get a get a hit on
him and magneto gets pissed and so he
just like rips the adamantium out of his
body now the funny thing about this is
that Wolverine never actually screams
that's one of the big misconceptions
about the story is that Wolverine
screams the entire time it's happening
Wolverine never actually makes a sound
and as one of the things is said in the
comic if magnet if Wolverine could
scream like he'd be screaming for dear
life or something along those lines but
there's no sound that's made and the
result is that like Xavier freaks out he
loses mine and he ends up shutting down
the mind of Magneto
which ultimately leads it to the
onslaught saga but it's one of the
coolest things ever right because like
like well it was like crazy right it was
I mean it was like Chinese comics right
so it was like super high-octane fast
paced like kinda stuff well it was kind
of crazy at the end of the day it's
probably one of the most if not the
single most iconic moments of magneto
you've got basically at that moment
where he's like standing over Wolverine
Wolverines laying on the ground and like
the adamantium is basically just like
being pulled out of his body it's it's
it's kind of bonkers ultimately
Wolverine went on to become the feral
version of himself where you just like
running around in the woods with no nose
and bone claws fun fact it was the first
time that we learned Wolverine had bone
claws we didn't know that before we
always assumed his claws were given to
him by virtue of a demands
and they were never originally part of
his body but it's kind of nuts when you
get into it because you're talking about
a super like a super iconic moment with
this character the only moment that I
think would be comfortable comparable to
this was actually a story that almost
nobody knows about called Magneto darks
seduction and this was like a really
cool story from back in the day right
this this story came out eons ago it was
actually in 2000 when it was released
was like 19 years ago but there's a
point where magneto faces off against
the Avengers right so like Iron Man
she-hulk
um I want to say that like Hank Pym was
part of it Carol Danvers he faces off
against all these characters and
reverses the the blood flow of their
bodies in like it's pretty nuts cuz it
just leaves them like writhing in agony
and it end like that kind of thing was
insane right there like single-handedly
topple the Avengers we see magneto do
stuff like that before whether there's
one of those we talked about a second
ago where's like he's faced off against
multiple teams over the years it's
actually one of the ways I marvel kept
them popular was having a crossover and
face off against a bunch of different
superhero teams as opposed to just the
x-men but I'm curious which one you guys
liked the most right like I'm curious
what your all stance is like like which
moment you think is the most iconic in
the history of magneto and like feel
free to view Google searches right I
mean you know it's like I mean I don't
know how many of you guys know like your
favorite moments of magneto off top of
your head or like Noah's most iconic
moments or something like that maybe you
guys know maybe you guys know all that
stuff I have no clue but I had though
those are my two like my top two moments
are either are obvious ones like him
ripping apocalypse in half different
things like that but I'm curious which
one you guys prefer the most like which
one you guys think are the most iconic
moments of magneto in the history of
Marvel Comics but with that being said
guys we're to bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
and make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the robb core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]